you've written this a book and you've
got a lot of your friends to help out
called good clean fun what Andy and I
know but a lot of people may not know is
that you were a terrific woodworker
you're real craftsmen and you've put
together this really fun book there's a
lot of funny stuff in here you got a lot
of your friends to talk about just some
of the amazing things they've built you
learned how to work with wood from your
dad is that right yeah my dad and my
uncles and grandfathers taught me to use
tools but my dad you know the the source
of the book is encouraging people to
make things even if even if they're not
beautiful furniture even if you're just
fixing a step or something like the
first thing he ever made in our house
when I was about five no I was about
three he made what we called the tinkle
box it was a little pine box for me to
stand on so that I could tinkle like a
big boy and could you just look at me
and say that one more time so that he
made me a pine box that I could stand on
it and tinkle like a big boy
right then that just made me so happy
you want to duck out too happy Stan it's
in here I got it
Luke wait so he built this for you and I
think you think you included an
illustration of this memorabilia is that
supposed to be you or is that John
Wilkes Booth no that's that's me that's
you and you had a mistake you're so
angry about him too what are you so bad
about how heute that yoke huge that
toilet is yeah I could bathe in that
massive yeah those were good times my
friend Ethan Nicole drew that and he
does a he draws the cartoon axe cop he
has a whole bunch of stuff in the book
including a four-page homoerotic comic
book about me and Chris Pratt
yeah dumping down a tree right page 77 I
believe is it right here yeah go back
one god man it's just like watching
paint dry
oh this is nice right here this section
right here where you're at a nice
illustration of you rubbing rubbing
lotion into Chris Pratt's back
come on listen if you're gonna be in the
woods messing around with tools you
don't want to get sunburned no very good
you